a number of weeks back you really laid
into bla about how he was dressed right
and if you'll remember we asked him to
come back looking his best in a formal
suit and as sober a gentleman as he
could possibly be yeah I do think uh
there's a generation that's lost its way
and uh they're always wearing ironic
t-shirts and Kookie watches and bucket
hats and uh they're they're not kids
anymore bucket hats yeah yeah you know
what I mean just the whole oh and and
and and bla I've known bla bla has
worked with me for a very long time I
knew him when he was a kid and when his
attire was appropriate but for his own
sake I thought it'd be nice if he just
took a chance on dressing up and blle
here you are and I have to say you look
fantastic yeah bla come on over okay
come on over bla is here and um come on
in bla get over here look at him he
looks fantastic wow I don't like this
what do you mean that looks I think he
looks awesome you look very handsome but
this is not this is not everyday blle
well okay as you know him but if you
only knew Daniel Craig as a guy that
wore if I only knew Daniel
Craig keep your nighttime fantasies out
of my show if we if we only knew uh
Daniel Craig is a guy who wore cargo
pants and a ho farted
t-shirt and then he suddenly dressed as
James Bond one day you might feel like I
don't know about this but look you look
good thank you thank you I uh I don't
feel good why I feel weird man I feel
first of all there's I like to be uh
fashionable and I like to be comfortable
there's too many clothes on I'm wearing
too much clothes really well there's an
undershirt then there's this shirt oh I
didn't say wear an undershirt oh who
made you wear an undershirt well this is
what you wear when you dress up you wear
a suit you don't have I know but you
don't have to wear ant sure yeah this is
not blade this is not the blade I feel
like you're about to drive me to the
airport thank you look look I don't want
to I got nice shoes on look at these
shoes you got a normal watch on I got a
Rolex wearing a Rolex wait a minute
where did you get the wait where it a
birth birthday present from my from my
mom yeah little ro ro wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
stop the show okay your mother on your
birthday gave you a Rolex is she
president yeah what the hell well
because she knows I like watches and
like my mother on my birthday would make
me a poached egg yeah and I like houses
my mom doesn't buy me a house what are
you talking about you got a you got a
this is going in a whole different
direction now you you always make fun of
my watches and so and so I thought I
wear a nice watch because you always
wear watches where it's a joke the watch
cost $3 it's bright yellow it's made of
marshmallow it doesn't tell time it's
from Japan got a nuclear reactor thing
you got to count up the minutes whatever
yeah and it's isn't it funny I can't
tell yeah okay thank you thank but your
mother gave you a yeah my 40th birthday
it's a nice birthday she gave me a nice
a nice and my whole point being this is
me dressed nice and I I will I you look
great I don't think I don't see a
problem I came in today every single
person looked at me weird everyone's
like uh like h no first of all everyone
thinks I'm either going to a funeral or
presiding over if you well first of all
or or you're actually the body or you
look like they just po the
just gave it one last check to make sure
if this guy's really gone oh yep he's
dead all right I don't like you neutered
him I like you neutered Blake I think
first of all where did you get the
suit I I got I got the suit at uh I
think at Macy's okay Ser all right well
it looks good it's a nice black suit
it's a classic thank you now I'm just
going to say Rox watching a Macy's suit
huh well it's it's it does say uh made
with recycled polyester on the inside
it's by it's by J J forart classic J for
there's my boy first of all you didn't
say I have to wear a nice suit you just
said a suit nice suit thank you yes it's
a nice suit it's recycled it's recycled
which may explain why it doesn't feel uh
terrific okay it's because you're
wearing uh 800 uh liquefied bottles on
your back it is very hot the suit is
very warm okay well you chose to wear an
undershirt that's on you and can I tell
you something there are ways to dress
well okay and and earn the respect and
and of people around you without going
this far meaning you don't have to wear
a tie you don't have to wear a buttonup
shirt we told him to come in as formal
as possible though in his defense you
know well well we wanted to go the other
end of the spectrum yes yes and uh I I
am just saying that I want you to
consider you're not a kid anymore right
okay I think I looked it up I think you
were born in
1956 it's close yeah uh no no how old
are you uh 45 okay you're 45 yeah you're
not a child
and I do sometimes uh look at you and
think oh you're you've got the Peter Pan
syndrome you're still dressing as a
child and maybe that's going to
influence your life negatively maybe
potential Partners may not take you
seriously if you go into a club they're
going to say uh what's going on with
this guy right you know why is he at the
club telling this guy he has Peter Pan
yeah well but can I just what to wear at
the
club but I I Club fantastic
of course the greatest Club down inros I
feel like I don't want to give some a
potential partner a a false bill of sale
a false false good like they know what
they're getting right they know what
they're you know what you know it's like
ah and they might like Japanese watches
I don't want to I don't want to attract
someone who thinks I have more than one
nice watch you can still wear those
goofy funny watches where oh look it's a
watch but guess what I have no idea what
time it is um cuz it has no hands it
just has a face that cries sometimes I
do have one that you can tell the time
by oh yeah what's that Adam well part of
the conversation is this mik Con yeah
part of the conversation last time was
also around you know looking
professional in the workplace and right
so that's one thing I think I think you
do look really good and there have been
studies that say you know if you dress
for the job you perform better yes you
like lose the stress of wondering what
people who wear uniforms often perform
better I think because they're they're
like not looking at what other people
I've always liked uh I always liked Uh u
in Show Business when people took Show
Business seriously and dressed up when
they came on a talk show I always
thought that was kind of nice um and uh
and and I think we have an environment
here at our
company uh people are coming in they
know that con O'Brien's going to be here
this is no but you what I mean there
there's an expectation that people will
dress up this is like the comedy Vatican
oh my God I understand what ad saying
I'm just not not that I'm same but like
me being the pope headed by tyrannical
figure with only symbolic then uh and
then you guys uh no no I'm the voice of
God on Earth and then uh you guys are
like Swiss guards you know you're there
and you're holding your Pikes and uh we
not even like Bishops or anything oh God
oh God no no you're just standing
outside with those Goofy axes that no
one's used in over 800
years but bla um I'm just I think that
Adam brings up a good point which is
when you dress the way that you dress
yes you're just going to have goofy
ideas you're just going to want to go
eat a burrito you're just going to go
want to grab your you know uh your Wii
controller Nintendo switch gum gum and
uh and play your game of uh gorar and um
all this sounds great though no no no
but but you you this doesn't sound like
an argument you Al so I'm agreeing with
you that sounds all that sounds you
still do all those things right but
dress like someone who commands my
respect wait can I say something though
I think what Adam's saying is right if
you work at like an accountant office
but if you work for the circus right
which we do which this really is an
absurd place the lion tamer is very
well-dressed the ring Master is very
well dressed trapes artists in their own
way are quite elegant in fact most
people at the circus are very nicely
dressed in their own costume let's say
your job is to pick up poop like you're
a civil worker and you pick up poop
you're not going to dress up in a suit
when you're picking up poop you dress up
but you wear a uniform you wear un even
someone who's picking excrement from the
sidewalk as they're living and by the
way I'm not putting that job down that's
a real job saying that's my job is on
this podcast is to pick up poop now I'm
saying that there are certain
environments that have certain
qualifications how about this how about
this not dressing up and wearing a suit
and a tie but Adam as the the head
honcho here the overlord the uh scheming
monster The Man Behind the Mask he's a
bishop yeah um I look at Adam I look at
Adam Sachs and I say Bishop material
yeah um uh but um what I'm saying is
what about like boiler suits that say
Team Coco on the back wa you want to St
like coveralls hold on no not hold on no
that's hold on what I'm saying
is something akin to that like what they
wear at a nuclear power plant yeah
doctors nurses they wear uniforms you
know all in those like the army of
coveralls and hard hats and GES yes I do
I would like it if everyone Eduardo if
we came up with something that was kind
of cool would you be up for wearing it
here at Team Coco I'd be up for it I'm
on team Conan on this uh I like because
because it would be nice and look at the
way it D we the Lakers hat yeah but if I
listen I I used to sell Man suits for a
living at Mac's actually but that was
six months
ago uh I I I do believe it's important
to dress to impress um whenever possible
now and all I'm saying is and you you
know look I love the shirt you're
wearing it looks fantastic a
CR a a cranberry t-shirt that been
overwashed you have good memories from
college about you you what are you
talking about I'm weing it's like you
killed a mechanic and then tried to pass
not at all this is came home to his wife
and said I'm home honey what are you
talking about I know is your collar
popped up make a decision like what is
it look I think I look fantastic and
I'll tell you something else I look like
I could be a film director no I could be
a director on a film you're dressed like
Lenny from Of Mice and Men yeah well
want to see the rabbits no your Blues
are too close okay listen I like to wear
blue cuz it makes the old peepers pop
and it's and uh it worked for Sinatra
and I think it's working pretty well for
me uh before we go Adam I do think I
want to pursue this idea I want to see
if we can find something that the men
and the women are all okay with wearing
that's a kind of a standard uniform I
like it and then I want us the cameras
to be rolling when we break this to Andy
RoR and we watch him physically beat the
you to wear this uh well that's
interesting yeah they're G be standard
host scarb like host have their own I
will I will wear something consistently
as a bond villain does the bond villain
you jacket I would wear like a n jacket
and I'd have like a fake white cat that
i' pet but then you guys would do for
that but I do think there's something
that we should investigate there might
be a great way and and also what about
like young people that are just starting
out here uh working at here and their
brand new employees maybe they have to
wear the boiler suit but then there's a
then there's a it's like the Army then
there's a rank above that but we wear a
uniform now I'm starting to get on with
this this is oh I'm no I'm not okay well
go ahead John Wick you know how like the
people that work the patching the
telephone calls they have style and then
the Continental has its own sty gu what
I love I mean I love the John Wick films
I would first of all you're dressed
Allah John Wick right now and that's why
I think it looks cool I love the John WI
so what we're we're talking about is
like tears of the utilitarian people the
administrative the talent and they're
all thematically linked but they have
their own specific look are you into the
into it now I'm getting there okay okay
and and this would be paid for by the
company you would come in you would you
would leave in your uniform you'd come
here and change into your uniform would
would have lockers and I'm and and would
change into them and I'm not even
kidding I'm not even kidding we' change
into them and um Sona you would have to
go to your locker and change your
clothes I don't want to do that well
you're going to do it and I'm going to
be there when it
happens God I
Hon no I honestly no no no you won't see
me there there'll be a window there'll
be a window that only I'm allowed to
look through and again I haven't I don't
I don't read the papers much and I don't
go online much but I don't see any
problem in today's society
with me having a little peeky
window oh God anyway Adam get on
this going to go through the roof we're
going to we're going to figure it out I
took a class in college on costume
design so we can I can I can work some
things up you know what guess what if
gle's in I I I I'm I don't want to do
anything to dissuade Matt gorley I want
you in on this so yes you can have a
final say I promise what final say okay
done I'm in
are you kidding well looks like I did it
we
win